I discovered that he had put images up
on a porn site of me so did the cops
help you no they didn't law enforcement
doesn't take crimes that occur online as
seriously as they should my apartment
door was kicked in they threatened to
murder our children they threatened to
murder our pets they stalked us
[Music]
I'm at mature Burdine and this is a
story about three women with all too
common stories of targeted online
harassment I spoke with a domestic
violence survivor attacked with revenge
porn a former banker who was stalked
online and a game developer relentlessly
harassed during what became known as
gamergate if you've ever heard the term
gamergate you've also likely heard of
Brianna Wu I went to see Brianna present
her case to a caucus meeting in Cohasset
Massachusetts why is this such a serious
issue because the Internet in 2018 is
our public sphere this is our coffee
shop this is our town hall she spoke
about the male-dominated gaming industry
and got responses like this I hope you
enjoy your last moments alive on this
earth you did nothing worthwhile with
your life even a video of a man with a
skull disk holding a knife up to the
camera and saying Brianna whoo this is
gonna be the last thing you ever feel
tonight me stabbing this through you in
2017 41% of Americans reported facing
online harassment during their lifetime
an increase from 35 percent in 2014 of
those nearly one in five experienced
serious targeted harassment like
stalking or physical threats young women
are especially likely to experience
sexualized abuse one-fifth of women
between ages 18 and 29 report online
sexual harassment it would have been so
much easier for me to just sit down to
be quiet to keep my mouth shut to do
nothing and just wait for them to go
attack some other woman I was looking at
a lot of research reading about your
case and there's a lot of information
yeah that is purposely intending to
mislead people
people love to click on dirt whether
it's true or not right and right now
Google's algorithm deliberately rewards
that behavior I wanted to understand why
technology platforms struggle to build
safer spaces and why law enforcement
sometimes fails to take internet
harassment seriously I'm Liz Lee
I'm the founder and executive director
of online SOS so online SOS is a
non-profit I started it to help targets
of online harassment and why did you
start it well the issue is pretty
personal to me I was just a girl out of
college I just graduated moved back to
New York City starting my first job in
finance you know excited to be in the
real world and getting these strange
emails I got an email that had a kind of
an implicit threat in it where like if
you don't show up on this day you know I
will do XY and Z but I didn't know what
to do about it do I tell my employer do
I tell my parents and it's one-on-one so
it doesn't matter if anyone knows about
it it's just meant for the target to be
afraid so you said you were stalked my
apartment door was kicked in yes I was
getting a ton of phone calls at this
point I knew who it was and it was an
ex-partner and they were stalking me and
I couldn't do anything to stop the phone
calls nonprofits like online SOS are
often targeted simply for being
outspoken an organization called crash
override that started in the wake of
gamergate
disconnected their hotline because of an
overwhelming need for assistance with
online abuse outpacing their current
resources I don't want people to suffer
alone
I think suffering alone and in silence
is the worst outcome the benefits of an
open Internet and the connectivity of
platforms have a downside allowing
people to harass others anonymously and
easily my name is Adam dodge I'm the
legal director at Laura's house which is
a domestic violence agency serving all
of Orange County the Internet has also
become the weapon of choice for exerting
power and control in domestic
relationships we don't typically see a
case come in for a restraining order
that doesn't have some type of virtual
or online harassment component to it
it's a public health crisis hiding in
plain sight domestic violence hotlines
in America get 20,000 calls per day
one in three women has been a victim of
violence by a partner during their
lifetime we do over a thousand
restraining order cases every year and a
lot of those cases don't involve
physical violence they involve
harassment online shaming virtual abuse
next I wanted to hear from a woman who
was targeted by her ex-husband with
so-called revenge porn I discovered that
he had put images up on a porn site of
me
these were images that he took of me and
[Applause]
one in 25 Americans have experienced
non-consensual explicit image sharing or
been threatened with it that number
rises to one in ten for women who are
under 30 what would you say to young
people to teenagers who say these kinds
of photos I just say don't do it we had
children you know we went to church we
you know we did all the things that made
us elect the perfect family I mean we we
look like the perfect family to
everybody it was when I got out of the
shower and he took him how did you feel
when you saw them on the site I felt
completely violated and betrayed so did
the cops help you no they didn't they um
actually one of the police officers tell
me he didn't wasn't sure if it was a
crime because I was his wife and then it
just doesn't go anywhere a sheriff
investigator yeah filed it criminally
what the DA and then they rejected it
most states now have laws banning
non-consensual pornography but a
national law has been stymied in some
cases even by free speech advocates like
the American Civil Liberties Union it's
really important that we craft a law
appropriately to make sure that we're
not sweeping in protected speech so why
is intent so critical without a strong
intent requirement it could be a crime
for example to share an image of the
famous napalm girl the Vietnam war
protest photo the burden of proof often
lands on survivors both law enforcement
and platforms ask for documentation of
images it's a very humiliating thing
it's not something you wanted someone to
know I asked her about trying to use the
legal system to get images taken down
wasn't easy to do but I got the courage
to go to court I have I had to show the
images Facebook also asks survivors to
submit images that can be flagged my
name is Karen Annan I manage global
safety policy programs at Facebook we do
rely very heavily on the community to
flag content that violates our community
standards we have some tools that run
that catch content like nudity like the
photo DNA tool that I talked about for
catching child sexual abuse images but
we do rely on the community to report
content as
just in the first quarter of this year
Facebook reported deleting more than 21
million pieces of adult nudity when
you're building a social network and
you're excited about connecting people
it's much harder to think about oh
people are going to find their if
they're their stalkers are gonna find
them online and they're gonna harass
them there rahul focuses on algorithms
and the design of platforms it's
important to note that the business
models have dictated how those
algorithms behave not any technology
limitation algorithms should be talked
about like mirrors these mirrors reflect
our society three-quarters of women who
have been harassed online changed the
way they used platforms like Twitter and
Facebook and 32% of women stopped
expressing their opinion online on
certain issues in order to do this work
we have I have to be more public and if
that leads to harassment at this point
I'm okay with it
numerous talented outspoken women
refused to do interviews for this story
for fear of being harassed I know a lot
of women that you know when I'll say hey
do you want to talk to this particular
media outlet else about feminism they'll
say no it's just too risky I don't want
to be targeted so we have a system right
now that really rewards women for being
silent hey guys it's a flood that was
episode two in our five-part series
about the dark side of Technology be
sure to watch the rest of the episodes
right here and don't forget to subscribe
to AJ Plus